بيفضل يتغير المناخ كان شتاء و 2023 رحيما
حتى الان بالاوروبيين وكانه خذل موسكو
دافئا كما ذكرنا بالامس دفئ اضعف قوه احد
اقوى الاسلحه الروسيه الطاقه وقف الحظ مع
اوروبا في لعبه المناخ والطاقه العام
المنصرم كان ثاني اكثر الاعوام حراره على
الاطلاق في اوروبا اما اسيا فاشهدت انخفاض
استهلاك الغاز الطبيعيه امرا ما اقل الطلب
وبالتالي استطاعت اوروبا
خزانته الوقود لديها لكن الحظ وحده لا
يكفيه اوروبا
الاتحاد الاوروبي اوقف استيراد الفحم
والنفط الخام من روسيا دولنا مثل فرنسا
وهولندا وايطاليا عادت اليه تشغيل محطات
الفحم المتوقفه واليوم جاءت امداداته
الانقاذ من درويش كما تتفاوضت الدول
الاوروبيه على عقود طويله الاجل للغاز
المسال ووصلت اول شحنه بالفعل من واشنطن
لي برلين التي دشنت ثلاث محطات تخزين
جديده هذا الشتاء يتوقع ان تغطي ثلث
تحتياجاتها السابقه الاتحاد الاوروبي لم
يكتفي بالهروب من فخ الطاقه
قد يؤثر الامر اقتصاديا على موسكو عندما
تدخل قيود الغرب على صادرات ان يقتل روسي
حيز التنفي فبراير الشهر المقبل يتوقع ان
تنخفض الامدادات الروسيه من المنتجات
البتروليه بنسبه 50 الى 60%
الطاقه سلاح موسكو الذي بات موجها ضدها
اليوم على الاقل ولناخذ مثالا بسيطه
الروسيه كانت تمتلك نحو 20% من اجمالي
مصافي المانيا قبل ان تاممها برلين لكن
روسيون اخر تعرض سرعه الالماني للتامين
لتتجنب برلين خطر الانهيار الاقتصادي
الكامل
الجماعيه للمصانع في المانيا وتانين الغاز
والكهرباء عن المنازل الذي كانت تخشى منه
الحكومه الالمانيه لم يحصل فخزانات الغاز
هنا ما زالت مليئه رغم ان الغاز الروسي لم
يعد يصل منذ اشهر طويله فالحكومه
الالمانيه نجحت باستبدال الغاز الروسي
بغاز من النرويج والولايات المتحده
والجزائر من بين الدول اخرى نجحت ايضا
بافتتاح اول خزان عائلي الغاز المسال في
البلاد بسرعه قياسيه قبل نهايه العام
الشتاء الدافئ نسبيا ساعد على استخدامه
كميات اقل من الغاز والمساعدات التي
قدمتها الحكومه ساعدت كذلك على تهدئه
مخاوف المواطنين والشركات من فواتير باهظه
ومن بين هذه المساعدات وضعوا سقفا لاسعار
الغاز والكهرباء ومساعدات ماليه نقديه
قدمت لشركات
افرد هذه الخطوات السريعه وان كانت باهضه
التي اتخذتها المانيا ساعدتها على التعايش
سريعا من دون الغاز الروسي على الاقل في
هذا الشتاء